mais de l'aco
miley cyrus aime provoquer vu pas moins
de 600 millions de fois sur youtube on
lui attribue aussi la popularité du taur
king une forme de danse suggestions
virage étonnant pour cette artiste qui a
fait ses débuts à l'âge de 13 ans dans
le rôle d'hannah montana une émission
jeunesse produite par disney il ya eu
des films des albums et progressivement
la jeune ado a multiplié les coups
d'éclat proposer plus c'était beaucoup
une stratégie de marketing qui en
rappellent d'autres pour moi qu'est ce
qu'on ferait au même sens que madonna
par exemple qui m'a donné industrie sage
quand on le connaît au tout début du
début est de plus en plus et les prix
contrôler que sa carrière et s'est
affirmé comme femme est ce que votre
rôle loin sur ce territoire
à 21 ans elle joue maintenant dans la
cour des grands comme madonna est bonne
je vis elle a fait appel à montmagny
factory pour son spectacle qui
s'arrêtera à montréal et toronto au
cours des prochains jours
on est engagé au début pour toi qu'on a
fini mon affaire cinq ans on a fait
l'introduction d'aller voir au début du
spectacle on voit le visage du mali en
groupe ou au travail source de bull à
mon amie on voit un chien à travailler
sur ce petit bout leur côté aussi
esthétique humoristique là dedans c'est
intéressant aussi poussé la tournée
obtient de bonnes critiques mais si
miley cyrus réussi à imposer son style
unique elle le fait au détriment de ses
admirateurs de la première heure selon
pierre marchand quand on a des enfants
qui aiment les sirènes sont dits mvno
montana on peut pas envoyer à 10 12 ans
miley cyrus parce qu'une cassure
complète que la fatalité public mais ça
fait parler d elle donc on peut pas dire
que ça fonctionne pas
la question demeure miley cyrus fera
t-elle carrière aussi longtemps que
madonna ici tanya lapointe radio-canada
à montréal